hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over
the bishop's opening what starts out
with e4
e5 and bishop to c4 someone recently
reached out and requested i do this
opening and my
initial thought was surely i have done
this over the last 11 years
a pretty common opening i just thought
for sure i had
already done a video on this but i had
not so today we are going to write that
wrong
and make a video on the bishop's opening
now a lot of people
after they play e4 e5 they always think
yes knights before bishops and so knight
to f3
is way more popular than bishop to c4
but there's a lot of play that you can
have with bishop to c4 we're gonna be
looking at the three main
lines that you will see from black that
is knight two f6
knight two c6 and then bishop here to
c5 the first variation we are going to
look at
is knight to f6 attacking the pawn here
on e4 so pretty
common response from white would be to
play knight to c3
uh and then black's gonna play bishop to
c5 bishop down here to b4
attacking that knight maybe the knight
to c6 just getting more
of the knights involved into the center
of the game here
uh the way i like to approach this is to
play the ursov gamut and that is to play
pawn to d4 now i have a separate video
i did on this particular version so if
you want to look more into this gambit
i'll have a link in the description
below as well as at the end of this
video but the two main ways that you may
see black approach this is the pawn
takes here
or the knight takes here on e4 now if
the pawn takes here well we're always
going to be playing knight to f3
attacking this pawn here on d4 and they
may play bishop to c5 to protect that
maybe knight 2 c6 to protect that or
just say you know what we're just taking
all the central pawns from white
we're going to play knight takes here on
e4 so those are the things you may see
if you bishop to c5 then we're going to
push forward with
e5 and this really starts to put a lot
of pressure on black because
there's not a lot of great squares that
black can go to
before white can really put a lot of
pressure on them knight take knight
comes back here to g8
and then all of a sudden knight to g5
and now the knight
and the bishop are both attacking his
pawn here on f7 which is extremely weak
because the black king is the only piece
defending it so maybe pawn two d5
trying to open up the center of the
board as well as attack this bishop
white can actually take here with on
passant this is a real move
uh white has one move and one move only
where they can take with on passant here
and so this still allows for a a strong
attack so you know
now they're almost relegated to play
this knight to
h6 to defend this f7 square
queen to e2 check king over here to f8
have lost the right to castle on the
king side anymore
pawn takes here on c7 things just go
extremely bad so maybe they
they realize that the knight coming back
here to g8 right away
isn't going to solve their problems if
they just play d5 right away
well now i think white can just take
here on f6 and yes they could take our
bishop as well but now queen to e2
uh bishop to e6 don't think there's
another option that black has here
but then we play pawn takes here on g7
they play rook to g8
and then bishop here g5 just getting
more pieces involved into the
action this is queen check here uh so so
many threats that white has here i
really really like
this setup if we come back maybe they
don't play that bishop here to
c5 maybe instead they play knight
to c6 okay from here we can just push
forward
with pawn to e5 uh sometimes
if you play pawn to e5 they'll play
queen to e7 because they recognize yes
you can take that knight but if we pin
it down to your king
then you're not able to do that now in
this case we're just gonna play
castle on the king side if they take our
pawn
we're just gonna take they take with
their queen we're gonna play rook over
here
to e1 knight down to e4 really the only
logical move but then pawn to
f4 attacking the queen we start to have
a pretty strong attack here now one
thing to keep in mind that
if they just come over here maybe queen
to f5
maintaining pressure on this f4 square
as well as still controlling the center
of the board
you really need to be extremely
aggressive and it looks pretty weird to
play pawn to g4 here because
you have both your pawns on the f and
the g file that it pushed up and there's
so much room in front of your king
there's no protection
but you have the advantage you need to
continue to keep attacking so if they
come back to
you know g6 we have f5 attacking the
queen
queen comes back here to c6 and then we
play
queen to d3 uh maybe pawn to d5
attacking the bishop if they do though
this would be a huge mistake because
bishop to b5 pins the queen down to the
king so
pawn to d5 is not really an option for
them
and so when you think about the pawn
can't come down to d5 how do they really
protect
this knight here on e4 this is going to
get captured by the rook
or the queen right here on d3
so very very difficult for black to hold
on to this position
and because of that this king here on
g1 is not under any immediate threats
and white has
so much more material attacking the
opponent uh that they should have a
pretty good game
in the spot now instead of playing queen
to e7 after we push forward with
pawn to e5 they don't have to play their
queen they could also just move their
knight since the knights under attack
knight 2 g4
attacking this pawn we are just going to
castle on the king side
they can't really take it here because
our next move is going to be rook here
2e1 regardless
but now we can just take and after they
take we're going to play rook here to e1
pinning down
that knight here but even with something
you know pawn to d6 doesn't really
matter because our next move is going to
be
pawn to f4 attacking the knight the
knight can't move it is pinned down and
so this
knight is going to fall now
instead of early on maybe instead of
knight two
c6 in this spot maybe they just decide
to take additional material knight takes
here
on e4 now yes white is down two ponds of
material
but they can immediately just get back
one of those pawns right here queen
takes here on
d4 and white has a lot more material
involved into the game and this is one
of those situations where you know this
is the airsoft gambit so you are giving
up a pawn for a very very strong attack
and so you're attacking the knight
knight usually is going to come back to
f6 it can try to get creative with
knight to c5
uh but i don't know that that's going to
be a very strong option for them so
maybe knight two f6 they've moved this
knight around a lot here you know it
came out here to f6
then it came down to e4 then it's come
back to f6 they really haven't moved any
of their other pieces we can play knight
to c3 and you can see
we have a pretty good setup we have both
of our bishops that can
easily get involved into the game we're
already attacking this f7 square
we can play knight to g5 to put a lot of
pressure on
this f7 square we can get our dark
square bishop involved into the game
pinned down that knight
we can cast on the queen side if we want
a very strong attack on
this d file we can cast on the king said
if we want to so a lot of different
options that white has
in this spot so those are some of the
things you might see in the airsoft game
but if they play pawn takes here on d4
but they could also just take with their
knight here on e4
we're always going to be taking this
pawn on e5
but one thing you have to keep in mind
is when you play pawn takes here on e5
part of the reason they played knight to
e4 is they're looking to play
queen to h4 potentially because this is
putting a lot of pressure
on the king side if you see this you
need to immediately take here
on f7 if not you are gonna have a
very very rude awakening because once
this knight moves then your
bishop is going to be under attack so
bishop takes here on f7
after the king takes now he can play
pawn to g3
forcing the queen to move and because
it's off of this
fourth rank here now the queen can come
to
d5 check and then after either the king
moves or the queen moves does not matter
the queen can come back and take that
knight here on e4 so always make sure
that you do take
that pawn here on f7 first before you do
anything else now if they want to attack
the pawn here maybe the queen down here
to h4 is maybe not on their their road
map here but maybe queen to e7
attacking the pawn i recommend playing
knight to
f3 you can try to get cute with queen to
e2
i just don't think it's nearly as strong
as knight to f3
uh holding down this pawn now and
not only are they attacking this pawn
but they're also threatening to move
queen
to b4 if they do this we'll need to be
playing knight to d2 because if there is
an exchange
knight takes here on d2 it does stop the
check here
but also defends this bishop here on c4
so you don't want to recapture here
because you're just going to lose that
bishop so always make sure that you
recapture with your knight here
on d2 somewhat of a tricky spot because
you do want to get your dark square
bishop involved into the game
uh but you definitely need to make sure
that you are protecting this bishop here
on
c4 now they may not decide to get their
queen involved into the game
instead they could just play knight two
c6 attacking this pawn
this is the case we're going to play
bishop takes on
f7 this is one of the reasons you play
the bishop's opening
is because you want the fastest attack
to this f7 square
you want to sacrifice material and you
want to be chasing your opponent's king
around the board as much as possible so
if they do this hey you take right here
now you can play
queen up here to d5 check and then after
they move you're gonna take
this knight here on e4 so that's really
what you're going to be thinking about
if they come down with their knight to
e4 e4
is how can you sacrifice your bishop and
then immediately
take their knight here on e4
the next variation we are going to look
at is knight to
c6 after the bishop's opening now you
have a couple options here
uh the first one would be to play knight
to f3 this is the italian game so if you
like playing the italian game then you
can just easily get into
this opening if you say hey the whole
reason i'm watching this video is i
don't like the italian game
show me a different option well you're
in luck because that's exactly what i
will show you
so pawn to d3 is my recommendation here
and part of the reason i like pawn to d3
is it almost invites my opponent to play
bishop to b4 sometimes my opponents
don't always know exactly what they're
going to do and so if you can invite
them into
lines that you like that encourages them
to go down a path that's going to be
beneficial for you
in this case we're just playing pawn to
c3 if they come back to let's say
a5 i really like the move pawn to a4 and
the reason for that
is it doesn't look like it's immediate
threat but it actually is an immediate
threat so if they play you know knight
to f6 which would be a huge mistake
they're actually going to lose material
pawn to b4
attacking the bishop the bishop comes
back here to b6 and you can see
that material is going to fall here so
while a4 doesn't look like it's
immediately attacking this bishop it
actually is so i like to put as much
pressure on my opponent
to not just think one move ahead but a
couple moves ahead to see
where my threat is so in this case they
could play you know pawn to a6
to prepare for the bishop coming back
here to b6 and then a7
uh but now i can just play queen or
bishop here to
e3 and continue to attack this dark
square diagonal here now if they don't
come back to a5 they could just play
bishop to
c5 that's fine as well pawn to b4
if they come back to b6 because they
could always come back to e7
that's fine as well but now a4 and it's
really just forcing their hand they have
to play
you know something like pawn to a6 or
else they are going to lose
material now if they don't play their
bishop out here to b4 maybe
knight to f6 in this case i'm just going
to be playing
uh knight to c3 may not be the most
exciting opening but we still can get
our dark square bishop ball into the
game pretty easily
then we can play queen up here to d2
castle on the queens that if we want to
we can cast on the king side we still
have options at some point if we wanted
to push forward with f4 we could play
knight to f3 at some point so we still
have
lots of options that we have that we
want
the last version we are going to look at
is bishop here to
c5 now this is another variation where
you have options
if you really like the gioco piano you
could play knight to f3 because more
than likely your opponent's gonna play
knight two
c6 this is something you say no i don't
like this i want to avoid this at all
cost
i have another option for you i've seen
some other people recommend
some other lines here i really like the
move
queen to g4 now usually people are not
going to recommend getting their queens
into the game very early
but i think in the bishops opening it
does make sense and the main reason i
like it
is because the way i see people play
against
queen to g4 almost everyone seems to be
playing
pawn to g6 to stop it yeah this stops
the immediate threat here
uh they also can't mirror so you know
one thing about these
openings they're just mirroring exactly
what we are doing they can't mirror the
move queen to g4 because they just
lose their queen if they brought it down
here to g5 so they can't do that they
have to figure out okay now how do i
change game plan here the pawns under
attack
pretty easy to just play pawn to g6 here
okay that's fine knight
or queen to f3 but they're almost always
playing knight to f6
they recognize that the threat is queen
to f7
checkmate so no one wants to fall for
that so they know they need to get
material involved into the game
and so they played knight to f6 and then
we can play the move pawn
to d4 and the reason why i like the
whole setup is this move right here
because
it's inviting them to take with their
pawn it's inviting them to take with
their bishop and
both of those are going to be a mistake
and i always want to put my opponent in
a position where they can make a mistake
so let's look at both of those options
so you can see just the threat that
white has
the first version we're going to look at
is the pawn takes here on
d4 and we're gonna push forward with e5
attacking this knight here on f6 and you
can start to see that one of the main
threats that we have here is if the
knight moves
then black is going to lose the game
this bishop
on c4 just putting so much pressure on
this f7 square
and the queen is just eyeing this down
so it's almost pinning down the knight
to
a checkmate uh so this is
a weird way to think about a pin but it
definitely is
pinning down that knight to a huge
threat here so how do they really
continue from here
uh well pawn to d5 they really have to
stop this bishop here
and from here we could play bishop to g5
getting more pressure on our opponent
now we're pinning down the knight to the
queen
an actual immediate pin here and so how
do they
continue if they take with their pawn
here on c4 to say okay
we just have to take that bishop because
we know that's an immediate threat here
okay well that gets difficult because
bishop takes here on f6 and this is
attacking the queen and the rook
black's going to go down a ton of
material here
and a pretty bad position but if they
don't let's say instead
maybe maybe knight to d7 says okay let's
let's defend that material here but
as soon as they do this knight here on
d7 actually blocks off the queen
from defending that pawn here on d5 so
white takes this material it still has
that huge threat here it's pinning down
the knight
so the knight can't move back still
loses to queen to
f7 checkmate and so the pawn can take
here the bishop can take here
you have three pieces the queen pawn and
the bishop all
eyeing down this f6 square and black
only has
two pieces to defend it so that's not
going to go well
either now if we come back and say what
if the pawn doesn't take here what if
the bishop takes instead
in this case our move order is going to
be a little bit different because before
we just push forward with e5 we don't
have that option
we can still have a huge
pin and that is the bishop here to g5
same thing the knight can't move because
then we could just play queen
to f7 checkmate so how do they really
continue from here
uh they really have to play something
like a d5
everything else is going to lose because
just bishop takes on
f6 this is going to attack the queen and
the rook that's going to go poorly so
d5 makes the most sense i'll show you
what d6 looks like as well
it's going to be bad but pawn to
d5 okay well now we can just play the
move pawn
to c3 and the reason we play pawn to c3
first we have to look at what happens if
we don't so if we just take
bishop here to f6 okay well now they
could just play
pawn to e4 taking that pawn they're
attacking our queen we're attacking
their queen they're not under check so
they're not going to lose the game so
bishop takes here
they take our queen we don't have the
threat anymore of
checkmate and so now it just comes down
to an exchange and who wins that
exchange so knight takes on f3
uh bishop takes on b2 and you can see
that's a critical square that we don't
want to lose here
bishop to f6 attacking the rook they can
castle
maybe bishop takes on e5 but then rook
to e8 pinning down the bishop
things are not very good and you can see
also the rook here on a1 is going to
fall so
that's not the variation that we want to
go down instead of taking with
our bishop here on f6 we can first play
the move pawn to c3
and things change drastically now they
can't just play pawn takes here on e4
because now we can actually take where
their queen up here and if they take
with their queen okay we take with our
bishop here on f6
attacking the rook they still castle on
the king side but now we take with our
pawn they take and now we take with our
bishop
and you can see we are miles ahead of
them we have
two of their minor pieces they have none
of our minor pieces
and we should have a pretty easy game in
this spot so they're probably not going
to take
with their pawn here on e4
after this position but then you know
what else do they do they could take
this bishop here
on uh c4 but still
they're they're going to lose because we
can just take this this knight here
on f6 so that's what happens if they
play
d5 it's not really a good option if they
play d6
things are just bad because we could
just take their knight here
on f6 and you can see attacking the
queen and
the rook that's a fork that they're not
able to deal with so that's why i really
like setting up this position because
you just run into that g6 and the knight
to f6
and then after pawn two d4 they just
don't know how to deal with it and both
of the options with the pawn and the
bishop taking it
are going to be a huge mistake so that's
reason enough for me to go ahead and get
my queen involved into the game with
queen to
g4 but that is the bishop's opening
hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video if you haven't
already please hit that like button
definitely helps out the channel a lot
if there are other videos sometimes i
think i've made videos for openings
and i just haven't so let me know in the
comments below or you can always
reach out to me via email but thank you
guys so much for watching i'll see you
guys in
the next video
you